sehr geehrte damen und herren als
präsident unserer gesellschaft für
politisch strategische studien kurz
stratec genannt ist es mir eine
besondere freude sie heute an den
empfangs einrichtungen unserer streaming
übertragung herzlich begrüßen zu dürfen
wir betreten mit dieser form der
heutigen veranstaltung zumindest für
unsere gemeinschaft absolutes neuland
und so gibt es nach den corona
erfahrungen mit home office und
homeschooling nunmehr auch den versuch
mit dieser elektronischen unterstützung
wieder eine größere anzahl von
zuschauern an dieser buchpräsentation
elektronisch teilnehmen zu lassen
ich begrüße sehr herzlich die
diplomatischen spitzenvertreter von
zwölf in österreich akkreditierten
botschaften und danke sehr
für ihr erscheinen
[Applaus]
ich bedanke mich beim hausherrn der
landesverteidigungsakademie general
leuten und magister eric kubitz für die
immer gewährte gastfreundschaft und die
besondere unterstützung bei der
vorbereitung des heutigen doch sehr
anspruchsvollen und herausfordernden
abends vielen dank ganz besonders darf
ich am podium die autorin des heute
vorzustellenden buches diplomatie macht
geschichte frau bundesministerin außer
dienst dr karin kneissl und mit ihr
respektvoll herrn bundespräsidenten
außer dienst universitäts professor dr
heinz fischer mit seiner gattin sowie
herrn hofrat dr erbin schmiedel sehr
herzlich begrüßen
[Applaus]
als präsident der stratec habe ich mich
außerordentlich gefreut dass dr fischer
als ehemalige oberbefehlshaber des
bundesheeres den vorschlag gemacht hat
diese heutige präsentation im rahmen
einer veranstaltung unserer gesellschaft
für politisch strategische studien
durchzuführen
sie sind ja heute hoch verehrter herr dr
fischer nicht zum ersten mal in diesem
haus und bei unserer strategie sondern
sie haben in ihrer aktiven zeit als
bundespräsident vorlesungen als
universitäts professor für
verfassungsrecht beim
generalstabslehrgang und auch einen viel
beachteten vortrag im rahmen der
strategie zur zukunft der europäischen
union gehalten
vielen dank
dass sie auch weiterhin dem bundesheer
und seinen vorfeld vereinen in dieser
außergewöhnlichen art und weise
verbunden bleiben
die moderation der heutigen
buchvorstellung hat dankenswerterweise
hofrat dr erwin schmiedel instituts
leiter für strategie und
sicherheitspolitik hier an der
landesverteidigungsakademie und
sozusagen der oberste haus historiker
übernommen
vielen dank auch dafür
ich bedanke mich bei der harris bildfunk
stelle für die kompetente technische
beratung der heutigen veranstaltung und
für die durchführung des streaming und
nun zum eigentlichen anlass für den
heutigen abend die vorstellung des neuen
buches steht hier vor mir von drk
rittmeister mit dem titel diplomatie
macht geschichte macht kann man hier
einerseits lesen als ein
herrschaftsinstrument auf der anderen
seite kann es aber auch ein zeit wort
ein thum wort eine tätigkeit darstellen
ich glaube dass auch diese
doppelbedeutung von der autorin durchaus
beabsichtigt gewählt wurde
meine damen und herren sie haben sicher
verständnis dafür wenn ich hier einen
stolzen einwurf erlaube und erwähne dass
frau dr karin kneissl nach wie vor
vizepräsidentin bei uns in der strategie
ist vielen dank dafür ich möchte dem
moderator des heutigen abends nicht
vorgreifen aber doch meine zufriedenheit
darüber ausdruck meiner zufriedenheit
darüber ausdruck geben dass mit der
maschinen dieses buches ein langer und
nicht immer leichter weg der autorin zu
ende gegangen ist
ich hatte die gelegenheit das buch in
vorbereitung des heutigen abends zu
lesen
und ich versichere ihnen dass es nicht
nur für diplomaten und politologen lohnt
es aufmerksam zu lesen
für manche wird es ein unüblicher
hinweis dafür sein dass man neben den
grundfertigkeiten des berufes wie
geschichtswissen und sprachkenntnisse
auch die befähigung zu einem
vertrauensvollen hintergrundgespräch
ohne vorgefertigte worthülsen und
sprechblasen mitbringen muss der
unerträgliche zeitdruck verlangt hier
manchmal ungebührlich viel
aufmerksamkeit auf den randvoll zu
gepflasterten terminkalender diplomatie
sollte mehr sein als das ausgefeilte
meist aber nichts sagende statement in
großer runde aber exzellenzen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren machen sie
sich selbst ein bild und lesen sie
dieses buch ich biete nun herrnhofer dr
schmiedel um seine einleitenden
ausführungen und bitten unsere kaputt
vielen herzlichen dank für diese
einleitung und vielen herzlichen dank
für die möglichkeit hier zu ihnen zu
sprechen ein paar worte zu wechseln
zum beginn möchte ich sagen dass ich
karin kneissl schon seit längerem die
freude und ehre habe zu kennen das ist
mittlerweile fast 30 jahre her ich war
damals zugeteilt dem außenministerium
und lernte eine junge aber
offensichtlich ambitionierte und gebilde
die kundige kollegin kennen in der
damaligen 2 4 der abteilung für den
nahen osten und afrika und habe also
irgendwo gleich am anfang den eindruck
gehabt dass es keine 08 15 diplomatin
sowohl im positiven wie im negativen
sinn
wobei ich sagen muss grundsätzlich
gesprochen die jungen angehenden
diplomaten im außenministerium sind
sicherlich die bestqualifizierten und
motivierten leute die wir im
bundesdienst haben
später werden manchmal die frustrierten
gesamten daraus aber das ist eine andere
frage
auf jeden fall was sie damals sehr
motiviert das ist ja heute auch noch ein
besonders interessanter punkt war dass
sie damals schon ganz jung gesagt hat
sie bewundert die engländer
da gibt es dann so typen die irgendwann
einmal sagen können ja vor monitoren
service for money foreign office uns ja
damals schon ein bisschen in diesem
zwiespalt zwischen diplomatie und
wissenschaftlichen journalistischen
interesse damit gespielt das
außenministerium zu verlassen
mittlerweile kannst du nicht mehr sagen
formulieren service sondern auch formal
von minister weil du ja dann in der
rolle der ministerin von 2017 bis 2019
wieder ins haus zurückgekehrt ist und
diese erfahrung diese doppelte erfahrung
der jungen diplomaten sowas zehn jahre
lang dem diplomatischen dienst und der
außenministerin ist natürlich die rote
linie der faden der sich durch dieses
buch
durchzieht wobei ich das ja noch eine
zweite verbindung erwähnen möchte du
hast als du in spanien im einsatz war
ende der neunziger jahre um es dann
geholfen den nachlass von glaubt er
kaufen oder einen teil des nachlasses
von berghausen nach österreich zu
bringen und berghausen war der gründer
der stratec das heißt da schließt sich
wieder da der kreis gewissermaßen kommen
wir zum thema des buches das ist sehr
schön geschrieben diplomatie ist das
institut des zivilisierten
zusammenlebens du hast ein widerspruch
völkerrecht oder das law of the jungle
das schon gerecht da und du hast eines
was sich auch als roter faden durch das
buch durchzieht als militärs oder im
militär kennen wird einspruch der wird
abwechselnd montecuccoli oder brennen zu
gehen oder wem auch immer zugeschrieben
zum kriegführen braucht man drei dinge
geld geld nämlich geld und du hast
diplomatie benötigt drei dinge nämlich
dialog dialog dialog und das ist glaube
ich ein bisschen ein roter faden die
aufgabe das gespräch aufrechtzuerhalten
respekt füreinander und dialog auch bei
missverständnissen oder bei
unterschiedlichen auffassungen zu zeigen
als ausgabe als aufgabe der diplomatie
und etwas was natürlich gerade auch in
zeiten wie diesen in zeiten des
übergangs und der veränderungen gefragt
ist
du hast in einem aufsatz aus dem jahr
2006 ein bisschen der vorläufer dieses
buches ist diplomatie zukunft mit
fragezeichen geschrieben
diskretion bestes attribut der
diplomatie gehört als ideal der
vergangenheit an entscheiden die
minister kabinett ist er pressesprecher
gute berichte der botschaften verstauben
kam auf als historischer schätze ich das
sehr weil die guten berichtet der
botschaften sind später eine wichtige
quelle
die frage ist nur wie sehr die berichte
der botschaften in die aktuelle politik
einfließen und das ist glaube ich das
thema was im schlaglicht der medien
transparent für den zuschauer geschieht
das entscheidet und prägt auch
diplomatische handeln hinter dem kuli
die diplomatie hat eine rolle in den
internationalen beziehungen zu spielen
durch hierfür muss sich von ihrer
jetzigen funktion postfach oder
reiseveranstalter für parlamentarier zu
sein lösen
das kann nur durch ein prinzipielles
umdenken und neues gestalten präsidenten
strukturen geschehen und das ist glaube
ich ein anspruch oder eine forderung die
eben nicht nur für 14 jahren sondern
auch heute durchaus aktuell ist und die
die in diesem buch auch ganz besonders
darstellst und begründet genau sie
gehört mich gebeten auch ein bisschen
zur geschichte der diplomatie zu
sprechen ist es etwas was natürlich
schon aus der antike kommt das wort
diplomat leitet sich vom griechischen
diplom ab das heißt vom gefalteten
dokument und das falten des dokuments
und das verschließen des dokuments
implizierte vertraulichkeit und das ist
glaube ich auch ein punkt den du zu
recht immer wieder anspricht die
entwicklung der diplomatie du stellst in
dem buch auch da von der antike über die
entwicklungen im mittelalter sind
zunächst einmal persönliche gesamte
personen die reisen unternehmen aus der
österreichischen tradition könnte man
siegesmund von herberstein nennen
wir haben gerade vor wenigen jahren erst
500 jahre sondern seiner reise nach
moskau gefeiert im frühen 16 jahrhundert
immerhin 69 auslandsreisen unternommen
hat was für die zeit eine ganz
beachtliche leistung ist und der sowohl
im dialog mit dem osmanischen reich wie
mit russland eben eine ganz wichtige
rolle gespielt hat später im 18 im
neunzehnten jahrhundert entstehen dann
nicht nur die ständig vor ort
befindlichen botschafter sondern eben
auch die apparate die ministerien
manchmal ihren durchaus ambivalenten
verhältnis zwischen den missionen und
den apparaten zu hause und sobald ein
apparat entsteht ein ministerium
entsteht stellt sich die frage der
koordination und das ist glaube ich auch
ein punkt den du immer wieder hier
ansprichst wesentliche veränderungen
in dem 19 im zwanzigsten jahrhundert der
übergang von territorial zur
nationalstaaten die geänderte rolle der
menschen der bevölkerung die von den
untertanen zu den staatsbürgern zu den
cds werden und damit natürlich auch die
rolle der diplomatie beeinflussen und
gleichzeitig auch die frage wie stabil
demokratien sind das ist ein beispiel
dass ich bis heute zieht ein präsident
obama hat vermutlich andere prioritäten
also interessiert ein traum
nur ein beispiel zu nehmen und das ist
natürlich eine frage die die diplomatie
im sinne der verlässlichkeit der
vertraulichkeit immer wieder beschäftigt
etwas was auch ganz interessant ist wie
vermengen heute oft und du sprichst es
auch an den diplomatischen und den
konsolen dienst
das war ein ursprünglich zwei völlig
getrennte dienste die in österreich
ungarn zum beispiel auch
unterschiedliche uniformen hatten
diplomaten waren grün konsolen waren
roth adjustiert bis 19.3 die auch andere
aufgaben haben die konsulate sind die
handelsvertreter zunächst einmal und
dann die es zu obhut für die bürger im
fremden land
währenddessen die diplomaten die
beziehungen zwischen den zwischen den
herrschern zwischen den regierungen
aufrecht erhalten sollten
und das ist auch eine rolle die heute
immer wichtiger wird weil einfach mehr
leute reisen und unterwegs sind und du
hast die schönen bezeichnungen vom nanny
state er sich um die staatsbürger im
ausland kümmern muss und wo dann halt
diplomaten oder komm schon manchmal als
babysitter auftreten
ein wesentlicher punkt denn du auch
machst und ich glaube ich sehr wichtig
ist diplomatie ist nicht außenpolitik
die außenpolitik formuliert die ziele
der politik auf der basis der interessen
letzteres wird in der realität manchmal
vernachlässigt die diplomaten sind
diejenigen die das umsetzen müssen
die diplomaten sind im prinzip das
werkzeug die die die das handwerk
ausführen du hast also
irgendwo auch die stelle von der
bedeutung des handwerks der diplomatie
hier erwähnt so harald nickel sondern
denn dort ihr zieht erst mit seinem buch
die plauer see beschreibt die
wesentlichen aufgaben des diplomaten als
informieren vertreten verhandeln und das
ist auch ein punkt der wesentlich ist
zwei zitate dem man sehr gut gefallen
haben 200 jahre alt sollten aber noch
nicht veraltet sein dass es von
staatskanzler metternich der für eine
leidenschaftslose außenpolitik plädiert
und vom französischen aussenminister
thalhaus der meint ein diplomat regt
sich nicht auf macht sich notizen und
auch das ist glaube ich etwas das sehr
viel aus sagt wenn du formuliert dass
die aufgabe der diplomatie ist druck aus
einer krise zu nehmen
dann kommst du zu der feststellung dass
alle diplomatie letztlich präventiv
diplomatie ist und das glaube ich gerade
wenn es um internationale krisen wenn es
um unterschiedliche ansichten geht sehr
wesentlich tun ernst einige beispiele
gerade auch aus der jüngeren
vergangenheit norwegen 1993 etwa in
palästina konflikt max fahren das tool
den niederländer 1990 er jahren wenn zum
ungarn in rumänien geht oder auch und
das ist glaube ich ein sehr wichtiges
beispiel den ksc de prozess
wobei gerade die verhandlungen die sich
über jahre hingezogen vor der
schlussakte von helsinki ein ganz
wesentlicher prozess waren ermöglicht
durch zwei faktoren einerseits waren die
vertreter sowohl von west wie ost wieder
neutralen und blockfreien staaten noch
ein bisschen unter dem schock der krise
sehr krise 68 sowas darf nicht wieder
passieren und das zweite vielleicht noch
wichtiger die regierungen und
staatskanzleien menden diese konferenz
wäre ohne die sinnlos daher konnten die
diplomaten dort in ruhe vorhanden
und das ist es wenn man mit den
teilnehmern am kreis cg prozess spricht
ein ganz wesentlicher faktor dass es
dann zur ausformulierung der protokolle
von helsinki die kommen konnte es sind
sehr viele punkte die du ansprichst sie
möchte ich jetzt nicht alle hier
erwähnen
ganz im gegenteil lesen sie das buch es
ist absolut lesenswert das ist glaube
ich ein wichtiger punkt etwas was glaube
ich schon sehr wichtig ist dass du auch
darauf hinweist die veränderung gerade
auch im rahmen der europäischen union
dass man sich kaum noch zeit zu
gesprächen nimmt das gespräche im 30
minuten takt abgearbeitet werden und als
historiker weise ich gespräche dauern
seit der geht es um stunden und tage und
nicht um 30 minuten und das dadurch
eigentlich immer mehr begegnungen zu
fototerminen mutieren als zu echten
dialog und das ist glaube ich auch ein
punkt den du immer wieder und ich glaube
auch zurecht ansprichst ein weiterer
punkt es ist habe ich schon ein bisschen
in dem buch den eindruck gehabt dass
eine sorge die ich immer verfolgt hat
dass ich immer mehr amateur diplomaten
politiker und sonstige einmischen in die
eigentlichen verhandlungen dass immer
mehr elemente der außenpolitik abgezogen
werden
zu den kanzler ämtern oder
premierminister ämtern oder was auch
immer das hier immer mehr einerseits
berufspolitiker wir haben wir auch nicht
immer qualifiziert dazu eine rolle als
quasi diplomaten spielen und
andererseits elemente der diplomatie
ausgelagert werden an andere agenturen
an think tanks im bereich der beratung
pr agenturen wenn es um tätigkeit im
ausland geht
und das ist glaube ich ein ganz
wesentlicher punkt und ich habe das
eigentlich so was als warnung empfunden
die sich durch das buch durchzieht
kinder hört auf mit dem blödsinn
das war also schon da einigermaßen
deutlich und eine glaube ich auch gerade
aus deiner erfahrung dass außenminister
stammende gewisse skepsis gegen
europäischen auswärtigen dienstes kommt
auch durch du hast erwähnt dass sie
kennen sicher alle das büro von das
amerikanischen secretary of state
kissinger wenn es in europa gibt er
hätte gern eine telefonnummer
du schreibst krisenstaat später ab
geleugnet dass zusagen
inzwischen habe ich aus einem von einem
ehemaligen berater von joe biden
übrigens vor ein paar jahren in altbach
dann die fortsetzung gehört inzwischen
hat die eu eine telefonnummer
und wenn man die wählt dann kommt der
automatische stimme für die französische
version der europäischen politik drücken
sie einst für die deutsche version der
europäischen politik drücken sie zwei
für die englische version der
europäischen politik drücken sie drei
und so weiter also etwas was nicht
unbedingt eine einheitliche linie hier
angingen lässt ein punkt der glaube ich
auch durchaus wichtig ist auch im
hinblick auf manche neuerungen
wir kennen seit einigen jahren robin
attachés robbing botschafter laptop
botschafter nennst du sie und ich ein
problem dass er mir also immer schon
erschienen ist im bereich der
diplomatischen missionen die zum teil
kurze verweilzeit im besten fall drei
bis vier jahre wenn jemand überhaupt
noch präsident ist von den rowing
vertretern rede ich jetzt gar nicht und
wenn man dann historische beispiele
anschauen christoph graf khevenhüller
1730 jahre botschafter in madrid
das ist eine andere dauer nicht albert
von mensdorff pouilly dietrichstein war
seit 1898 in london und blieb bis 1914
dort davon zehn jahre als botschafter
januar schmackhaft paravicini war von
1906 bis 19 18 botschafter in
konstantinopel das heißt wir haben hier
vertreter die lange dort sind die die
kultur kennen die die gebräuche des
gastlandes kennen die daher eine ganz
andere vertrautheit auch aufbauen können
setzt sich übrigens nach dem ersten
weltkrieg ford georg freiherr von und zu
franckenstein spielt das wort george
frankenstein da immerhin von 1920 bis 9
in 38 österreichischer gesamte in london
war also es gibt hier also durchaus auch
lange tradition an etwas was general
schon angeführt hat das problem der
vertraulichkeit vertrautheit die im
gegensatz zu manchen neueren
entwicklungen es gibt so schöne
schlagworte wie public diplomacy die
medienarbeit und ähnliches die gerade in
den bereich der vertraulichkeit manchmal
im widerspruch steht und etwas was du
natürlich auch erwähnst die probleme
nicht nur im amerikanischen bereich mit
einer passiv diploma 65 diplom asse
transformative diplomatie das heißt
einer diplomatie die auch ziele der
veränderung verfolgt und zwar auf eine
art und weise die eigentlich mit
traditioneller mit traditioneller
diplomatie nicht mehr in einklang zu
bringen ist etwas was ja auch sehr
wichtig ist gerade aus einer doppelten
erfahrung im außenministerium heraus und
dann hast du dir noch an einer
entsprechenden abschnitt gewidmet ist
die frage der ausbildung der diplomaten
wo es eben nicht nur um wissen geht
sondern um bildung sehr stark
historisches wissen dass historiker kann
das natürlich nur unterstreichen
und dass das eben wichtig ist auch für
die für das verständnis wesentlich auch
die frage der auslands kulturarbeit die
manchmal dinge möglich macht die im
offiziellen bereich nicht möglich sein
also ich denke nur ende der 1980 er
jahre gab es dann plötzlich in budapest
erste südafrikanische konzerte muss also
noch lange keine diplomatischen
beziehungen gab und ähnliches letztlich
hast du eine forderung eigentlich am als
kern des buches es geht darum das
diplomatische handwerk neu zu erfinden
und du hast also ein kapitel extra
betätigt betitelt die notwendigkeit
alter diplomatie in einer zersplitterten
welt und ich glaube das ist auch ein
sehr
sehr wesentlicher punkt ein sehr
zentraler punkt dass du eben gerade in
einer zeit wo wir eigentlich immer mehr
der diplomatie bedürfen
die notwendigkeit ist ihr alte
traditionelle erprobte und bewährte
formen wiederzubeleben und neu zu
erfinden
also als ökosystem kann ich eben nur
sagen lesen sie das buch es ist absolut
interessant und damit darf ich jetzt
über leighton zu meiner zweiten rolle
hiervon einleitung redner zum moderator
ich glaube der einfachheit halber bleibe
ich gleich da stehen bevor ich jetzt
hier platzwechsel und darf einmal mit
einer frage an bundespräsident fischer
beginnen eine ein roter faden der sich
durch das buch durchzieht ist eine
aversion gegen speaking notes gegen
gesprächsnotizen die die
gesprächsmöglichkeit ersetzen und du
beschreibst sehr schön die ministerräte
wo die einzelnen teilnehmer ihre
gesprächsnotizen vorlesen und ansonsten
dann aber nicht mehr zu hören sondern
ins handy schauen und herr
bundespräsident sie haben wir auch eine
erfahrung mit speaking notes und
präsident regeln gehabt wenn ich nicht
das recht erinnere ich möchte schon
zunächst einmal sagen ich betrachte mich
wirklich heiß als bücherfreund ich halte
ein buch für ein kulturprodukt besondere
art ich traue mich sehr in gegenwart des
russischen botschafters kaum sagen aber
ich habe vor 55 jahren eine biografie
von trotzki seine autobiografie in der
hand gehabt ihr 1927 auf seiner
verbannung sin verschlimmert und da das
eine seine gefängnishaft in sibirien
beschrieben
was da alles erdulden musste und wie
schwierig das war aber schreibt er dann
ein gutes buch oder ein stück papier und
bleistift haben mir über alle diese
schwierigkeiten hinweg geholfen als ein
kompliment an mein buch es ist ein
schöner zufall dass wir heute abend sein
buch vorstellen dass unsere
österreichische außenministerin aus
jüngster vergangenheit geschrieben hat
und morgen früh im presseclub concordia
ein buch meines freundes jean asselborn
des luxemburgischen aussenministers
vorgestellt wird das wir haben zwei
bücher zum bereich außenpolitik ab
sofort aber auch noch nie so ein setting
gerne bei einer buchpräsentation ist
eine gute idee das so einen
hochkarätigen kreis einzuladen und dass
wir mit elektronischen hilfsmitteln dann
vielen anderen interessierten zugänglich
zu machen
ja ich habe das auch gefunden dass das
bild in not die frau bundesministerin
offenbar sehr provozieren und dass die
die mit durch die speaking not
vielleicht verloren geht
die bereitschaft sich mit einem thema
wirklich substanziell
auseinanderzusetzen bei matthäus beginnt
not und im besseren fall schaut man sie
sich rechtzeitig an und memoriert sie im
schlimmsten vor lässt man sie vor an ort
und stelle also das ist ja dann nicht
schön und ich habe der frau
bundesministerin erzählt das erscheint
ihr imponiert zu haben dass mich der
österreichische bundespräsident
kirchschläger während seiner
präsidentschaft hatte eine einladung zu
einem staatsbesuch in den usa präsident
ronald reagan bekommen und er hat mich
ich war damals wissenschaftsminister in
der österreichischen bundesregierung
es war mitte der 80er jahre hat mich
eingeladen gemeinsam mit meiner frau an
diesem staatsbesuch bei ronald reagan
teilzunehmen
kreisky war damals gerade ausgeschiedene
des bundeskanzler ist 1983 aus dem amt
geschieden und ich habe ihn immer wieder
regelmäßig besucht in seiner wohnung in
der ein priester gasse und eines tages
bin ich ganz stolz beim gewesen und habe
gesagt ich habe eine riesenfreude daher
bundespräsident hat mich eingeladen ihn
auf seinem staatsbesuch bei präsident
reagan zu beteiligen der kreis geht
gesagt hat es wird aber schon fad werden
häufig so etwas wie wieso ist durch der
mächtigste mann der der westlichen welt
hat uns gewiss segen west segen der
stadt der regen der wird ein paar nette
worte sagen dann wird er ein zettel aus
der brusttasche ziehen so groß wie eine
größere zigarettenschachtel
da werden fünf points draufstehen die
wir der opfer werden dann wird er den
zettel einstecken und das gespräch wird
beendet sein
ich habe mir gedacht lieber herr
altbundeskanzler übertreibt manchmal
sehr wir sind nach washington gereist
wir sind mit einer freundschaft
empfangen worden
der präsident hat der bundespräsident
die airforce one als als ein instrument
zur verfügung gestellt und dann war dass
das meeting im weißen haus und wir
sitzen dort alle das war meine frau war
dabei das war protokollarisch perfekt
inszeniert
und wie wir so sitzen auf einmal greift
der regen in die brusttasche nimmt einen
zettel heraus genauso wie ist der
kreisgruppe zeit hat ich ich wäre
beinahe hätte ich zu lachen begonnen und
hat seine fünf punkte vorgetragen
zum glück war es dann so dass er nachdem
der fünfte punkt beendet war er nicht in
zetel eingesteckt hat und die sache
beendet war soll er hat dann noch ein
paar höfliche fragen gestellt und man
ist dann aufgestanden und hat noch ein
bisschen geräte das war ja auch der vize
präsident bush dabei und es war der
innenminister der amerikanische dabei es
ist letztlich ein interessantes gespräch
aber die speaking notes sind wirklich
weltweit verbreitet das ist das ist
warum das ist richtig und ich würde
vielleicht überhaupt als einen
diskussionsbeitrag sagen ich glaube dass
bei der außenpolitik und bei der
diplomatie zwei dinge zu unterscheiden
sind
das eine sind die prozeduren pro
features und das andere sind die inhalte
und die können in sehr unterschiedlicher
weise verknüpft sein es kann sehr
angenehme prozeduren geben aber sehr
fein harte und schwierige und
kontroversielle inhalte und es kann im
inhaltlich ein hohes maß an
übereinstimmung geben aber bei den
prozeduren vieles nicht so laufen wie es
laufen könnte also im idealfall müsste
außenpolitik und diplomatie und das ist
ja nicht identischer verhängt aufs
engste zusammen
inhaltliche substanz haben und
langfristige perspektiven haben und von
werten und von bestimmten
grundprinzipien geprägt sein
einerseits und andererseits muss auch
das handwerkliche stimmen
und wenn sich ein hochrangiger diplomat
oder einen regierungschef vor den
außenminister in gespräche begibt und
auf sein gedächtnis und auch sein auf
sein wissen vertraut und in der hand von
bruno kreisky wien ihren spickzettel
oder eines peking- not gesehen ist es
gut wenn er glaubt der präzision halber
unter um nichts zu vergessen und rund um
die die vorbesprechungen entsprechend zu
berücksichtigen braucht das beginn notes
noch bei nord soll das sie verwenden
wenn sie in die richtige richtung führen
und wenn sie von der substanz und vom
inhalt her passen
das war ihre frage ich möchte nur noch
sagen ich habe das buch auch schon vor
einigen wochen dankenswerterweise
bekommen und und gelesen und ich würde
sagen man spürt dass das buch von einer
expertin in ziemlich langer und
langwieriger arbeit geschrieben wurde
von einer diplomatin expertin
journalistin und dann noch einmal
überarbeitet und angereichert wurde um
die erfahrungen einer außenministerin
weil beides schimmert durch die seiten
durch die die experten position auch in
den historischen darstellungen in den
vielen fußnoten quellen und anmerkungen
das kann man ja auch rehabilitations
schrift einreichen einerseits und
andererseits dann der korrigierende
ergänzende hinweise aus der praxis und
diese kombination hat mir sehr gut
gefallen ich kenne nicht viele
außenminister in österreich
die bücher geschrieben haben ein kind
jetzt alle durchgehend vom figl an
und gruber und wie sie alle heißen haben
in der zeit vor dem staatsvertrag und
dann in der großen koalition und viel
außenminister hammer gehabt seit 45 mehr
als ein dutzend mehr als 15
wahrscheinlich und gott so viele bücher
aus dieser richtung gibt es ja nicht
dankeschön
vielen dank herr bundespräsident
vielen dank sehr geehrte damen und
herren exzellenzen und auch ein großes
dankeschön an den kommandanten der
landesverteidigungsakademie und alle
guten geister die das heute hier
ermöglicht haben und die bei erbin die
worte des bundespräsidenten freue mich
aufrichtig weil sie haben es in einer
nussschale dargestellt genau das was
passiert ist ich habe mit diesem buch an
sich im jahr 2002 angefangen immer
wieder ran daran geschrieben einem
verlag gesucht keinen verlag gefunden
dann hatte ich einen verlag dann hat
sich andere arbeiten wodurch
außenministerin zu meiner eigenen
überraschung und als ich dann letzten
sommer beim verlag wieder an fragte
würde sie das buch immer noch
interessieren sagt ja und so ist genau
das passiert was bundespräsident fischer
so klar auf den punkt gebracht hat ich
habe es dann überarbeitet eben mit der
sicht von ihnen
und weil überdies peking not schon
allerhand gesagt wurde ich habe der
anfang der neunziger jahre die
gelegenheit für den damaligen
außenminister alois mock als kann man
jetzt mitarbeiterin tätig zu sein und
habe noch einen außenminister damals
erlebt der sich auf seine treffen
manchmal sehr akribisch manchmal je
nachdem wie es eben auch die zeitung
weiter erlaubt hat weil die noch andere
tätigkeiten neben seinem außenminister
tätigkeit was in meinem fall weggefallen
ist was ein großer segen war
ich habe mich als fach ministerin
gesehen aber das gespräch war ein freies
und das war das faszinierende und diese
gesprächskultur dass sie uns weggefallen
ist für ist für mich ein grund warum uns
heute in diesen vielen patt situationen
befinden
also ganz ehrlich gesagt ich hätte kein
zweites mal den besuchsraum gemacht
immer mehr organisierte am rande der
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen in einer woche 40 termine oder
so ich habe am schluss wirklich nicht
mehr gewusst wo getroffen habe und mit
wem ich was besprochen habe hätte ich
mehr zeit gehabt dann hätte ich es
gemacht genauso wie ich es endlich von
wien erlebt habe nämlich sich viel viel
mehr zeit zu nehmen für das gespräch und
ich sage östlich von wien dann war das
wirklich so dass hier einfach zeit in
einer ganz anderen form wahrgenommen
wurde wir hatten das delegations
gespräch und wir hatten danach das essen
das essen ist etwas ganz entscheidendes
eben auch im sinne der gastfreundschaft
miteinander zu essen und ich habe
bewirtung auch entsprechend hoch
angesetzt wenn ich einen gast hatte egal
ob staatssekretär außenminister wie auch
immer aber dass man befürchtet und all
das ist weggefallen das ist weniger
geworden und westlich von wien gibt es
dann manchmal gerade noch einen kaffee
und auch die termine die dann oft sehr
kurzfristig verändert werden abgesagt
werden die unverbindlichkeit die da ist
also da hat sich meines erachtens allein
in diesem kurzen zeitraum von mitte der
neunziger jahre bis anfang der
nullerjahre gewaltig viel verändert das
hat mich überrascht bei meiner rückkehr
und dieses big lots sind ja mehr als
eben gedächtnisstützen es ist gut wenn
man eben dieser spielzeit und hatte man
diese vielleicht auch noch einen zettel
zugeschoben bekommt von einem
mitarbeiter ein gutes briefing des
residenten botschafter sagt achtung da
ist noch dieses oder jenes thema zu
beachten das aber vergessen
aber wir sind eigentlich heute fast
schon in drehbüchern gelandet es sind
vorgefertigte drehbücher die mir gerade
innerhalb der europäischen union ich hab
das während unseres eu-vorsitzes gesehen
wir wirklich einander vortragen und das
hat nichts mehr mit dem politischen
gespräch zu tun und das ist für mich
schon ein grund warum wir in dem pub
sitzen in dem wir sind innerhalb der
europäischen union aber auch in den
platz zwischen europäischer union und
egal ob ich das jetzt wer immer hier
sich angesprochen fühlt wir haben sie
wissen wenn ich woran ich denke wenn ich
sehe diese papp situationen die da sind
und ich glaube dafür bedarf es einfach
eine andere gesprächskultur und da ist
dieses alte handwerkszeug der diplomatie
ein ganz wesentliches dass ich eben
möglichkeit schaffe in einer atmosphäre
die vertrauen schafft wo vertraulichkeit
gewahrt ist dass man das eine oder
andere heißen anspricht ohne dass man
sich eben weg ist wechselseitig moores
lehrt ohne dass man mit vorwürfen an
würfen dauernd in die öffentlichkeit
geht und wir sind einfach in einer zeit
gelandet in der das vertrauen auch
vertraulichkeit nicht mehr gegeben ist
das hat zuletzt der britische
botschafter in den usa erfahren müssen
hertha und eben einer sehr guten
situation wieder einberufen wurde
und das ist etwas was eben der große
heimische für die internationalen
beziehungen heute ist also ich glaube es
funktioniert einfach vieles nicht es ist
vieles zu öffentlich und zu politisch in
der diplomatie geworden und was
bundespräsident fischer eben auch klar
festgehalten hat eben dieses diese ist
unterscheiden und wo kann die diplomatie
eben dann den rahmen schaffen damit
vielleicht dann auf der politischen
ebene doch auch wieder etwas weiter geht
der frühere britische premierminister
david lloyd george hat bereits anfang
1919 gesagt diplomaten sind nur eine
vergeudung von zeit und geld wir die
premierminister können das selber tun
und genau dieses wir können das selber
tun hat dann gemündet in den pariser
vororten verträgen also wenn ich mich
als lloyd george wunderbar verstehe mit
meinem gegenüber thema so oder orlando
dann dann regeln wir das schon
untereinander und das 1919 begonnen hat
nämlich dieses direkte sprechen der
premier singh dieses direkte entscheiden
auch über sehr komplizierte aus
bullische dossiers und das war nach dem
ersten weltkrieg der feier
ich denke nur an die orient frage was
wir heute als mittel ost
das mittel ist ein ko schlag hinaus
konflikt 10 versprechungen die getätigt
wurden zusagen schriftliche zusagen
das ist alles inkludiert und man hat
dann sozusagen die junior diplomaten
gelassen weil letztendlich war die
rheingrenze noch viel wichtiger zu
erklären
als mögliche grenzen zwischen zu
gründenden arabischen staaten
und das alles ist hat uns mindestens 19
in die falsche richtung geführt und
heute stecken wir leben in einer
situation in der wir ja auch gerade in
europäischen union sehen der rat für
auswärtige angelegenheiten habt an
bedeutung absolut verloren
es ist der rat der staats und
regierungschefs und die staats und
regierungschefs gerade jetzt doch in
dieser phase in der wir drinnen sind
also ich bin statt deutschen
präsidentschaft wirklich von herzen
alles gute das ist eine ganz ganz
schwierige mission die bundeskanzlerin
merkel zu erfüllen hat ich habe vor
einigen tagen einen gastkommentar dazu
geschrieben die die das pflichtprogramm
das zu absolvieren ist und dann
vielleicht noch eine mögliche der
gestaltung wird jetzt überschattet von
rettungsprogrammen und wir sind in der
situation dass wir vielleicht wieder was
ins ohr gehen gesagt hat eben was
braucht es heute um die europäische
union zusammenzuhalten uns braucht es um
krieg zu führen geld geld geht
die vertrauensfrage ist jetzt gestellt
im sinne von wie viel geld sind wir
bereit dafür zu investieren um das werk
auf euch zu halten also dass das ist
jetzt einmal das dass das allererste
momentum aber genau dafür bedürfte es
glaube ich auch einer viel klareren
lastenaufteilung burden sharing wie wir
es ja im vertrag von lissabon vorgesehen
haben ja wo man in dem man bereit wäre
besser zu delegieren aufgabenteilung zu
machen und zu sagen wer kennt sich wo
aus nicht nur von den mitgliedern der
regierungen sondern auch von den
handelnden personen
es kann ja außenminister geben die sich
besonders gut im gebiet a und besonders
gut im gebiet auskennen last
die arbeiten delegieren wir an diese
oder es können andere ressorts seien
aber nein es wird sehr sehr stark
monopolisiert auf der ebene der staats
und regierungschefs und daneben auf der
anderen seite der kommission und das ist
meines erachtens eine situation die uns
offensichtlich in dem papier eingeführt
hatte also das handwerkliche vorbereiten
ohne dass wir uns jetzt noch einmal
erklären in kreisförmigen bewegungen wo
wir nicht miteinander können wir kennen
diese probleme alle hinlänglich das
führt uns nicht weiter und daher bedanke
ich mich für den zuspruch den das buch
bekommen hat es ist das was bleibt das
geschriebene wort und möge dieses
geschriebene wort vielleicht da und dort
auch inspirieren gewidmet habe ich es
unter anderem allen jungen menschen die
sich ernsthaft in den dienst ihres
landes stellen wollen weil es heißt
foreign service es heißt diplomatische
dienst
es ist nicht voran carrier es ist nicht
die diplomatische karriere die man
anfängt ist der dienst und als solches
hab ich es auch gesehen in dieser mit
diesem wunsch bin ich auch in das amt
getreten der außenministerin der
republik zu dienen und ich weiß wie
wenig dieser gedanke in verschiedensten
ebenen vorhandenes ich habe auch lange
genug unterrichtet und wohl leider das
wort karriere oder was noch schlimmer
ist job den dienst und das amt und den
beruf abgelöst hat
ja ich würde vorschlagen wir haben ja
hier so gewissermaßen die gebäude
diplomatische intelligenz in wien
vertreten
das heißt meine frage auch an sie
exzellenzen damen und herren botschafter
ob sie aus ihrer erfahrung da noch etwas
ergänzen oder ergänzend beitragen wollen
erwartungsvolle blick in die runde
bitte wenn sie mir erlauben würde ich
nicht als türkische botschafter einen
beitrag leisten sondern als ehemaliger
europaabgeordneter weil ich gerade
einiges gehört habe was probleme der
europäischen union betrifft und was sie
geschrieben haben
glücklicherweise habe ich auch das buch
bekommen und ich sehe da wirklich
unabhängig davon ob die türkei eines
tages mitglied europäischen union ist
oder nicht oder die debatte interessiert
mich persönlich nicht so groß momentan
aber wenig an die europäische union
zukunft der europäischen union und linke
und wenn ich daran denke was das wort
diplomatie dafür eine bedeutung haben
sollte kann ich nur bestätigen weil ich
so lange in brüssel als abgeordnete er
dann als vertreter einer einer
landesregierung land hessen bei der
landesvertretung wieder tätig war und
anschließend für die türkei in brüssel
unterwegs war bei meinen ganzen
unterschiedlichen erfahrungen einmal als
europa gehörte dann hessische
landesregierung im in politik vertreten
in brüssel zu sein anschließend
türkische regierung vertreten und in
brüssel zu sein
diese mischung hat mir eigentlich eine
erfahrung gebracht die ich bei ihrem
buch über äußerung was die äußerung über
europäische union das hat keine
bedeutung hat
ich könnte über kommission ewig lange
diskutierten eigentlich und wirklich
irgendwann hat man nur termine bei denen
man nicht mal einen kaffee trinken kann
also wird nicht angeboten und muss sich
einfach sagen ich hab' ich habe so oft
erlebt mit manchen ministerpräsidenten
die ich begleitet habe im europäischen
parlament zu manchen wichtigen
abgeordneten die große verantwortung
getragen haben und gastgeber erwarten
und dass die gäste waren wirklich
überrascht als es nicht mal ein glas
wasser auf tisch war ganz er war
wirklich halbe stunde angelegenheit und
nicht mal kaffee habe ich schon
vergessen aber nicht mal ein glas wasser
also ich kann vieles nur bestätigen was
sie geschrieben anfielen
darf ich da noch ganz kurz das passende
zitat aus karin kneissl anfügen im
orient nimmt man sich einfach mehr zeit
für den gast als diesem okzident der
fall ist so und ich darf weiter geben an
dem vertreter von ungarn
london ist mein name ich bin der
botschafter von ungarn
ich möchte gerne vielmehr eine art
persönliche bemerkung mache nun nicht
eine diplomatische oder beruflicher
bemerkung und im voraus muss ich etwas
einstehen eingestehen ich bin nicht
immer ein guter diplomat weil ich mich
schon einige male aufgeregt habe und
keine notizen geschrieben
was mich persönlich anbelangt ist ja ein
richtig gesagt wir sind im dienst wir
dienen und wir machen keine karriere
aber wir sind schon sehr privilegiert
also ich persönlich habe so viele dinge
miterlebt ich war fünf jahre botschafter
in israel
ich komme auch aus der politik aus
ungarn aber auch hier in österreich habe
ich so viele dinge miterlebt da sich
schon in israel angefangen habe ein
tages buch zu schreiben weil viele haben
mir gesagt was du mitmachen kannst
können nicht alle mitmachen für mich war
das normal und nach einer weile musste
ich feststellen und sie kennen bestimmt
dieses gefühl weil sie schreiben schon
seit 2002 dieses buch als wir es gibt
dinge die nicht alle miterleben können
und es ist wichtig solche solche bücher
zu produzieren oder eben tages bücher zu
schreiben ich schreibe das für mich
selbst vielleicht für meine familie also
nicht für ausgeben aber was sich
bestätigen wollte dienst aber
privilegien und man muss das irgendwie
doch schon in notizen verfassen können
danke vielmals auch für die einladung
heute abend ich habe das buch noch nicht
gelesen
deswegen kann ich mich dazu nicht äußern
aber vielleicht aus der perspektive
liechtensteins wir haben letztes jahr
300 jahre bestehen unseres landes
gefeiert und für uns ist eigentlich teil
unserer analyse dass wir ohne diplomatie
gar nicht bestehen würden
ich glaube das ist für einen kleinstaat
ganz essentiell
vielleicht eine eine grundsätzliche
bemerkung ich bin seit 31 jahren im
dienst meines landes und habe
festgestellt dass sich die diplomatie
ganz essenziell geändert hat in der im
weg wie wir wie wir dinge tun das stimmt
sicherlich in liechtenstein haben wir
die speaking notes vielleicht vor 15
jahren erst erfunden die gab es bis
dahin nicht bei uns waren berichte sehr
wichtig und die wurden auch sozusagen
gemeinsam gelesen und durchgekaut und
bei uns war sehr lange das amt des
außenministers beim regierungschef
was ich damit sagen will ist ich sehe
doch sehr stark das einfach und das ist
ein punkte auch gemacht wurde dass die
zeit fehlt es fehlt die zeit für das
verstehen für den dialog und so weiter
das sehe ich als eine einen wirklich
sozusagen einen eine wirklich sehr
wichtigen punkt was ich aber auch sie
ist das sehr viel technisches
mittlerweile bis zur chefebene kommt und
ich verständnis dafür hat dass man es
braucht also die speedlink notes ich
verstehen was gemeint ist aber ich
glaube wenn ein gewisses plädoyer würde
ich für die speaking notes machen weil
sie auch das produkt einer sehr langen
vorbereitungsarbeit sind die an einer
bestimmten stelle eben punkte punkte
gemacht gemacht werden müssen und
vielleicht ein punkt ja wir brauchen
mehr diplomatie aber teil der
schwierigen situation in der wir sind
ich schaue auch die tatsache dass der
politische wille fehlt und wir sehen das
gerade in der oecd
das wäre doch sehr stark an stoßen also
wir sitzen ja oder wirklich viel
beisammen und es ist durchaus
frustrierend zu sehen dass wir nicht
weiterkommen in so vielen themen und da
ist einfach im augenblick auch von der
politischen ebene der wille nicht da
sozusagen der kollektive und da würde
ich doch ein plädoyer auch machen dafür
dass wir sozusagen die mitteln die die
diplomatie hätte in der hinsicht zu
wenig genutzt werden im augenblick ihren
dank mein name ist bitter mit der
slowakische botschafter frau
bundesministerin hat eine matte hat
keine erfahrung mit der rat der
außenminister gemacht und ich habe vier
jahre als bester botschafter in brüssel
verbracht also ich habe auch meine
erfahrung gemacht ich verstehe worüber
sie sprechen
für uns war das manchmal mühsam weil wir
mussten stunden handeln um einen
kompromiss zu finden weil um etwas zu
erreichen um einen kompromiss zu haben
braucht man damals 28 aber das war
wirklich wir kämpfen um jedes kommando
ihres wort und manchmal war das für uns
nicht einfach festzustellen dass ich für
diese ergebnisse nicht so viele
einflussreiche persönlichkeiten oder
politiker die adressaten unsere
schlussfolgerungen die selbst sich
ständig auf der ebene der außenminister
gebildet wurden interessiert und das war
auch mit angst und frustrierend aber was
ich sagen möchte
aus meiner meine erfahrung aus meiner
sicht die persönliche beziehungen spürt
bedeutsame oder weil wir wussten unter
uns unter 28 dass diese botschaften
dieser wirtschafts und mit dieser frage
diese frage probleme haben könnte und
was uns aus dass wir auch persönlich im
gespräch
die situation geklärt also ich werde mit
daten damit nicht einverstanden sein
ich muss um diese position kämpfen weil
das ist für uns sehr wichtig und was mir
sehr geholfen hat dass wenn die kollegen
also empathie zeigen konnten weil sie
wussten ja heute hast du probleme hast
du warst probleme aber morgen kann ich
problem sein
und das hat wunderbar funktioniert
ein zweiter bemerkung frau
bundesministerin
ich bin der meinung dass wir also
diplomaten sollten unseren aus münster
helfen relevant zu bleiben
dass sie manchmal nicht einfach weil
inter regierungen gibt es politiker gibt
es verschiedene interessen verschiedener
probleme und manchmal haben dass die
außenminister nicht so einfach sich
durchzusetzen und das ist auch eine
rolle eines erfahrenen diplomaten seinem
außenminister zu helfen relevanz zu
finden dieser seinem komplizierten welt
dankeschön slowenische botschafter in
kenia spieles ich habe auch das buch
noch nicht gelesen aber was alles schon
gesagt wurde kann ich mir vorstellen es
geht um edle diplomatie etwas was wir
alle am liebsten machen würden
ich kann aber einiges über die erfahrung
mit der durch die arbeit mit
bundesministerin kneissl erzählen sie
war nicht eine langweilige
aussenministerin mit viel charakter und
das habe ich geschätzt
wir haben zwei außenminister treffen
vorbereitet und man konnte es sehen sie
hat sich in die materie vertieft und bei
dem zweiten treffen also ich kann jetzt
verfolgen weil sie was heute hier gesagt
wurde
also ich hatte es mit viel wissen und
viel viel charakter gemacht und mit auch
resultat kann ich sagen wir haben es
wirklich sehr geschätzt dass man zum
beispiel bei der frage der lipizzaner
einen eine vereinbarung gefunden haben
dass im interesse nicht nur so von
slowenien und österreich und von pferden
war sondern von der ganzen region und
heute morgen alle länder die lipizzaner
zug machen bei unesco eine gemeinsame
transnationale nominierung und das ist
unser gemeinsamer erfolg aber das hat
die ministerin verstanden durch
vertiefung und und offenheit auch den
anderen zu verstehen weil nur so kann
man gemeinsame interesse finden und
verwirklichen und wir schätzen sie dafür
das sind ja alles interessante und
wichtige themen
ich möchte einfach damit dass nicht
ungesagt bleibt drei punkte kurz
erwähnen die mir wichtig sind wenn nicht
über politik oder über außenpolitik
nachdenke dann beschäftigt mich ganz
besonders
erstens die frage was ist eigentlich die
rolle der einzelnen persönlichkeit des
einzelnen politikers in der geschichte
wie weit macht eine person geschichte
oder wie weit trägt die geschichte eine
person ist eine uralte frage wie kahn
oft ein wichtiges buch darüber
geschrieben haben schon mal geredet herr
botschafter aber sie ist eigentlich
nicht beantwortet und es ist ja auch
tatsächlich eine eine wechselwirkung wie
sehr ist der präsident chinas derjenige
der die weichen stellt oder wie sehr
haben die entwicklungen und die probleme
chinas einen mann wie den jetzigen
präsidenten an die spitze gehoben und in
welchem verhältnis stehen diese beiden
fragen
das zweite ist die rolle der geschichte
gibt es auch diesen weiten diskurs
manche sagen
die geschichte lehrt aber sie hat keine
schüler die ihr zuhören und andere sind
sehr überzeugt davon dass die geschichte
sehr wohl eine prägende kraft ist ich
gehöre dieser zweiten gruppe an
ich sage österreich hätte sich nach 45
nie so entwickelt wie es sich entwickelt
hat wenn es nicht die lehren aus der
zeit zwischen 1918 und 1938 oder 45
gegeben hat ich glaube dass jede epoche
der geschichte eine vorgeschichte hat
und die vorgeschichte eine vorgeschichte
hat und somit der einfluss der
geschichte nicht unterschätzt werden
darf
obwohl der nicht schematisch berechnet
werden kann weil andere faktoren eine
rolle spielt aber wer sich mit politik
beschäftigen will muss sich auch mit der
geschichte der entsprechenden
politischen periode beschäftigen und das
dritte ist der faktor macht welche rolle
spielt der faktor macht für die struktur
für den aufbau einer gesellschaft
es ist nun mal so dass es auch soziale
gesetzmäßigkeiten soziologische
gesetzmäßigkeiten gibt sowie
physikalische gesetze in der physik sind
die gesetzmäßigkeiten auf komma und
beistrich berechenbar
die zahl pi mal dem durchmesser ist der
umfang eines kreises und bekennen wir 3
1 4 1 5 792 auf unendlich viele
dezimalstellen in der in der frage der
macht und der machtverteilung ist das
nicht so exakt berechenbar und dennoch
spielt das eine riesige rolle und macht
hat die tendenz der akkumulation von
macht und hat die tendenz auch
gegenmacht hervorzubringen
und es ist nun einmal so dass nach 1945
eine eine bipolare situation gegeben war
zwischen usa zwischen west und ost
washington/moskau kommunismus
kapitalismus und aus gründen die ihre
ursache haben und geschichtliche wurzeln
haben und auch mit dem machtfaktor in
zusammenhang stehen verändert sich das
und ist zb momentan eine situation nicht
nur im entstehen sondern entstanden wo
neben der usa und europa und russland
das zurückgefallen ist in gewisser
beziehung im verhältnis zu china zum
beispiel eine neue macht konstellation
entstanden ist die sich nicht nur auf
die internationale politik sondern auch
auf die nationale auf die innenpolitik
auswirkt und durch schläge
und neue fronten schafft und diese diese
faktoren die zweifellos feststellbar
sind aber nicht mit der exaktheit von
physikalischen faktoren bereichen
vergleichbar sind
das finde ich das faszinosum der politik
das ist das interessante der politik da
gibt es unschärfen da gibt es
variationsmöglichkeiten da gibt
kombinationsmöglichkeiten und dieses
problem wird immer komplizierter je
vielgestaltiger die völkerfamilie ist je
mehr das was ich in europa abspielt auch
auf den fernen osten einfluss hat und
umgekehrt
umso mehr player auf der politischen
bühne stehen
umso umso komplexer und interessanter
werden diese zusammenhänge und das ist
auch ein bereich der bei der diskussion
eines buches über international über
außenpolitik und diplomatie nicht
unerwähnt bleiben soll
offensichtlich ist dass sie haben
apostrophierte gesprächskultur und diese
auch in beziehung gesetzt zu zeit und
geld wie sehen sie die herausforderungen
für die diplomatische arbeit durch die
digitalisierung und vor allem durch die
künstliche intelligenz die eine enorme
steigerung der reaktionsgeschwindigkeit
bedeuten kann und vor allem der
unreflektierten reaktion das ist eine
sehr interessante frage weil ich mir
manchmal gedacht habe wenn wir uns hier
als avatare sehen ja die sozusagen mit
einer software programmiert wären wie
würde das dann ablaufen dieses treffen
noch emotionsloser wie ist ein toller
rang 1 gefordert hat und dann metternich
ja das würde ich auch vielleicht
manchmal helfen
oder ist es dann doch wiederum wichtig
dass eben dieses gewisse etwas diese
käme diese sympathie zwischen menschen
entsteht oder wie auch botschafter musik
ist sehr schön gesagt dass er seiner
erfahrung dieses verstehen der andere
ist es gerade in einer schwierigen
situation und morgen kann ich vielleicht
probleme verursachen und genau das ist
aber glaube ich würden dann diese
avatare nicht beherrschen
und darauf kommt es aber an es ist ich
muss wissen wie geht es meinem gegenüber
im moment politisch ist er gerade eine
innenpolitische krise ist er gerade als
ablöse kandidat vielleicht medial unter
druck oder wie auch immer
und wenn ich das ein bisschen mitdenken
dann also ich habe es vermieden dann
wirklich das gesamte drehbuch
entsprechend vorzubringen weil ich
gewusst habe
manche dinge kann man im moment
vielleicht nicht gerade sagen eignet
sich nicht hebe ich mir auf für ein
anderes mal ja oder für ein telefonat
ich muss es ja jetzt nicht so zu sagen
wie es vielleicht die künstliche
intelligenz vorgebracht hätte und genau
dieses menschliche verständnis wo spur
befindet sich mein gegenüber moment es
auch bundespräsident fischer sehr schön
formuliert hat diese unschärfe dieses
einschätzen können von macht und gegen
machte ihm gerade im entstehen begriffen
ist
das macht dann eben letztendlich aus und
genau da
ich glaube ich muss man dann diesen
goldenen mittelweg aller konfuzius
finden im sinne von machbarem interessen
und ich glaube der große vorteil des
diplomatischen akteurs und dieser
privilegierten situation habe auch ich
mich gefunden als eben unabhängige
fachministerin nicht einen wahlkampf
messen zu müssen nicht
stimmenmaximierung am wochenende
betreiben zu müssen das muss der
politiker das muss vielleicht der
außenminister der politisch eben auch
nominiert ist aber der beamte der
diplomatie botschafter der gesamte die
nummer drei ist davon frei und kann eben
etwas anderes schaffen
es gibt personen die könne sehr gut
wandeln zwischen den welten rotation hat
dass es gerade auch in dieser eben war
zwischen wandeln welten und es ist dann
eben die jeweilige biografie die
entscheidet und es mögen immer menschen
handeln und nicht künstliche intelligenz
softwareprogrammierung das wünsche ich
mir sehr
und wenn er sich der fall sein sollte
dann wünsche ich mir einen stromausfall
bei einem solchen treffen
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin liebe
karin also ich hab das ist plädoyer für
den diplomatischen teams vernommen und
das kann ich auch voll unterstreichen
das ist überhaupt keine frage gerade in
zeiten wie diesen wenn du freihand
hättest und den diplomatischen dienst
wirklich nach deinen vorgaben
reformieren könntest was wären die drei
wichtigsten punkte
dank talente hereinholen und diesen
talenten das gefühl geben sie können ihr
talent ausleben und sie haben immer
perspektiven und das gilt für alle
ebenen also wir haben ja ein
österreicher mich glaube das gilt für
viele der hier anwesenden stadtvertreter
die unterschiedlichen kategorien a b c
mit den grenzen ja wie wir es eben auch
hier an dieser akademie wir haben den
generalstab wir haben die offiziere und
so weiter werden die grenzen und wie
weit kann ich jedem einzelnen die
perspektive geben
es ist nicht die gläserne decke gleich
nach 34 jahren erreicht und das gilt für
diese unterschiedlichen kategorien und
das gilt aber auch für männer und frauen
und das gilt für menschen mit kindern
ohne kindern familie also dieses diese
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf ist
für den rotierenden diplomaten oder
diplomaten ja noch viel brisanter als
jetzt für den fachbeamten einem ressort
der vielleicht eben sie die schulische
ausbildung der kinder anders
mitgestalten kann also wenn ich immer
rechnen muss ist da mein kind oberstufe
unterstufe habe ich immer oder wo man
die matura wehrmacht wehrmacht die
nachhilfe die ehefrau also dass das sind
glaube ich alles dinge wo man
perspektiven geben um eben dieses
ausleben durchleben und genau zu
verhindern warum ich ja ausgestiegen bin
nach neuneinhalb jahren
aber ich habe die gläserne decke gespürt
auf so vielen ebenen menschlich und
beruflich privat was wie wie kann man
als frau darin bestehen und ich glaube
diese gläserne decke ist zu nehmen das
heißt es gilt sehr sehr viel im sinne
von perspektiven geben diese
perspektiven immer wieder aufs neue
aufrecht zu erhalten
in der ausbildung weil jeder
außenminister auch dienstgeber ist
nummer eins nummer zwei wenn ich die
diplomatie neu erfinden könnte wollte
und so das wort sei dass heute immer
wieder gefallen
zeit nehmen und ich bin dankbar für all
die interessanten längeren gespräch
führen durften in einigen fällen das war
gerade eben auch im fall mit meinem
slowenischen kollegen und auch eine
wunderbare erinnerung wird froh dass das
noch funktioniert hat auch die zeit die
wir in peking hatte es war bemerkenswert
die zeit die ich in moskau hatte wo eben
auch ein man spürt der ist das
westfälische system funktioniert wir
sind ein kleiner staat aber wir sind die
jure sind wir gleich wichtig wie ein
anderer
und das ist leider aus der sichtweise
vieler anderer staatskanzlei abhanden
gekommen
da gibt es dann eben andere kriterien
ist datei
das kommando als nato-mitglied nicht
nato-mitglied was auch immer also es
spielen dann andere kriterien hinein
und da glaube ich eben dieses noch
gültige westfälisches system alles
souverän sind gleichberechtigt alle
staatenvertreter an sozusagen ihre rolle
das muss viel stärker gelebt werden über
auch dieses zeit geben und ich glaube
dass da kann man sich dann eben immer
wieder auch selbst um schneewittchen
packen und und das geben und es besteht
meines erachtens überhaupt keine
unvereinbarkeit zwischen den neuen
möglichkeiten die wir haben der
mobiltelefonie der digitalisierung und
so weiter und dem eigenen traditionellen
werkzeug für diplomatie sie können sich
wunderbar ergänzen und das kann man
leben
und keiner von uns geht in ein
restaurant und ist die speisekarte von
oben bis runter sondern man wählt aus
und dieses auswählen und prioritäten
setzen und sich eben für das ein oder
andere entscheiden das ist dann
sozusagen auch der mut zur lücke die man
haben muss aber auch das ist dann eben
die die dieses eben wichtig von
unwichtig unterscheiden können
etwas ganz ganz wichtiges und da würde
ich eben auch immer wieder der
diplomatie an die hand geben das ist
jetzt wirklich wichtig und die frage der
partnerschaft mit den medien ist meines
erachtens schon da und dort zu
überdenken weil public diplomacy hat
ihre meriten down dort aber es gibt
einfach die notwendigkeit der
vertraulichkeit unbestimmte dossiers
voranzubringen ja also ich bin für eine
rückbesinnung auf diskretion
sie ist die die alte dass das die
älteste eigenschaften dieser dieser
disziplin und ich würde sie wiederum
stärker ins gewicht fallen lassen ich
weiß dass das schwierig ist vielleicht
teilweise auch unmöglich aber es ist
eine übung wert eben indiskretion auch
gewisse dinge zu lösen
das wären die drei wesentlichen
dimensionen danke dir für die frage
weiter
der motor verloren
vielen dank
ich möchte gerne noch ein paar kurze
bemerkungen machen aber vor allem
heimische ich mich sehr herzlich
wirklich bei frau kneissl für dieses
buch bedanken
es ist einerseits eine sehr interessante
lektüre mit viel kenntnis mit viel
erfahrung mit viel recherchen
geschrieben man sieht eine wirklich sehr
große geleistete arbeit und ich glaube
für viele auch junge menschen wird er
sich wir das sehr hohen zu diesem buch
zurückzukehren
ich werde das unbedingt machen
es gibt aber es ist aber wirklich auch
ein sehr persönliches buch glaube ich
mit persönlichen gefühlen mit
persönlichen ideen die wie man bei
bei der lesung fühlt auch in den letzten
jahren zudem schon vorbereiteten text
gekommen waren
mir gefiel sehr dass dieses buch auch
gerade erscheint im erinnerung sie mit
vielen sehr wichtigen historischen daten
vor einigen tagen zum beispiel 75 jahren
der gründung von vereinten nationen und
viele andere aber nach der lesung dieses
buches glaube ich ist eine der
wichtigsten schlussfolgerungen für mich
zum beispiel dass es eine sehr
bedeutende bestätigung für die these ist
man kann und man muss aus der geschichte
lernen und auch aus der geschichte der
diplomatie
ich stimme vollkommen zu dass man kann
die außenpolitik und die diplomatie
natürlich nicht vollkommen gleichsetzen
aber was wir in den letzten drei vier
monaten alle erlebten alle botschafter
die in wien auch tätig sind
ich glaube es ist ein gefühl das nicht
nichts
das direkte gespräch und direkte
kontakte vollkommen vollkommen
ersetzen kann
es gibt schwierige situation in der welt
in der letzten zeit besonders die
kommunen besonders oft vor nacheinander
die wechseln sich aber die wichtigste
ist das spiel raum für diplomatie bleibt
wenn solche spielraum für diplomatie
bleibt dann ist es schon eine halbe
sache dass die lage nicht so schlimm ist
wirklich und vielleicht noch eine frage
die mich seit mehreren jahren auch
persönlich beschäftigt
sie wissen dass die beziehungen rust und
eu in einer tiefer sackgasse stecken
aber auch wo vor zehn jahren 15 jahren
entstand immer öfter die frage wenn wir
in unserem dienst
unsere botschaft den verschiedenen
europäischen hauptstädten gewisse themen
ansprechen
dann hörte man manchmal die
unzufriedenheit von brüssel aus und die
frage ist ob man nur mit der
europäischen union durch bronze
kommunizieren soll oder mindestens auch
durch europäische hauptstädte und die
frage bleibt für mich unbeantwortet weil
aus meiner persönlichen erfahrung die
außenpolitik der europäischen union ist
schon ein kompromiss und diplomatische
dienst der europäische union hat man
gefühl hat fast immer überhaupt kein
spielraum
und wenn es sich lohnt nur notizen
vorbereitete auszutauschen
dann lohnt es sich nicht mehr so zu
kommunizieren
in den letzten fünf jahren sind die
kontakte zwischen moskau und bronze mit
der europäischen union zu meinen
wichtigsten themen fast abgebrochen und
unsere gespräche mit einigen
hauptstädten mit einzelnen aufstellten
sind aber vertieft
ein kompromiss zwischen diesen zwei
seiten gibt weiß ich nicht aber ich
finde das auch nicht in ordnung das ist
das wäre meine fragen sehr voll genießen
acht enke hat und ich verstehe das
problem aber von seiten europas und
europa sowohl als summe von
einzelstaaten als auch als
völkerrechtssubjekt kann durch die
antworten die antwort nicht lauten
entweder oder sondern nur sowohl als
auch eine eine eine russische
außenpolitik einem oscar außenpolitik
wenn wenn ich mir diese diese kühne
diese kühne fantasie erlaube muss doch
darauf gerichtet sein
mit möglichst vielen der
eu-mitgliedstaaten gute und bestmögliche
beziehungen haben auf der einen seite
und auf der anderen seite ist es
natürlich wichtig dass es ist für
brüssel wichtig mit mit moskau
vernünftige beziehungen zu haben und das
ist für moskau wichtig mit brüssel
vernünftige beziehungen zu haben
jemand der sagt ihr müsst sich für eines
von beiden entscheiden
der stellt die falsche frage es muss
beides sein und es ist natürlich klar
dass das zwischen der qualität der
beziehungen zwischen ich weiß nicht
polen und russland einerseits und
westeuropäischen staaten ich will jetzt
keine hervorheben andererseits ein
unterschied besteht das hat auch
ursachen und an der an der überwindung
oder an der reduzierung dieser ursachen
kann man arbeiten und dass der kontakt
von brüssel und moskau wichtig ist steht
fest also das ist meine antwort auf
diese frage und wahrscheinlich könnte
ähnliches kollege li vom fond aus
pekinger sicht sagen weil ja auch die
beziehungen chinas zu einzelnen
europäischen staaten durchaus nicht
gleichartig kommt und gleich intensiv
sind und ein eigenes kapitel ist
beziehung brüssel china und in diesem
fall gilt es auch nicht entweder oder
sondern ein sowohl als auch
vielen dank ich hatte jetzt erstens
gelegenheit eine eine sehr wichtigen
einschätzung zu ziehen und zweitens gab
es mit gelegenheit der zeit nachzudenken
über eine inhaltsreiche antwort der eu
russland dialog so wie ich ihn
beobachtet habe bis zum frühjahr 2014
der dann aus den bekannten gründen eben
auf eis gelegt wurde war meiner
beobachtung nach damals vor allem ein
wirtschaftlicher dialog er war ein
energie dialog also ich erinnere mich an
pressekonferenzen ich habe ja auch immer
wieder zitiert für den unterricht wo es
eben um energiefragen ging und wo man
das gefühl hat die eine seite kennt sich
in dem thema sehr gut aus und prinz ist
und formuliert sehr präzise und die
andere seite hat eben weichere formen
und es war es war in erster linie
wirtschaftspsychologen energie dialog
und die geografie bestimmt nun einmal
oftmals die sichtweise und ob ich jetzt
aus madrid auf mosca blicke oder aus
moskau auf madrid oder rom oder ob ich
aus dem baltikum auf moskau blicke oder
aus
aus wo auch immer eben anderen
historischen einflussbereich das
bestimmt einfach auch sehr viel und da
glaube ich ist wie es bundespräsident
fischer ausgeführt hat genau dieses
sowohl als auch immer auch mit dem
verständnis für diese geographische
mitbestimmung das historische und wo
dann vielleicht dieser brüsseler dialog
manches technischer macht klarer macht
da geht es dann um millionen
kubikzentimeter erdgas für dieses oder
jenes oder es geht um einen austausch
auf der frage was leider in von der
europäischen union nie so aufgegriffen
wurde von russland vorgebracht nach nine
eleven
wie umgehen mit den terrorismus das ist
etwas was von russland sehr stark
aufgebracht wurde von europa in der
ganzen terrorismusdebatte erst dann
verstanden wurde glaube ich als 20 15
passierte
pater klang und so weiter aber das sind
eben da eine historische erfahrungen die
die erklärt werden müssen und wo der
technische das sehr wirtschaftliche
helfen kann dann vielleicht andere
befindlichkeiten ressentiments franken
und so weiter auszublenden
aber das was wiederum die bilaterale
diplomatie ja so schön macht und
weinbotschafterin gegeben wo wir auch
dieses allerhand erreicht haben diese
kultur diplomatie diese weichen themen
diese themen die emotionen verursachen
und wenn es auch nur ein zuchtbuch ist
von einer bestimmten pferderasse aber
das kann emotionen los treten die lange
nicht
nicht richtig unter dach und fach zu
bringen sind und ich glaube wenn sich
hier das bilaterale mit dem was das
institutionalisierte technische
ermöglicht auf ebene der europäischen
kommission wenn sich das gut verheiratet
wie man auf französisch so schön sagt
rosemarie pia dann dann kommt etwas ganz
besonderes heraus aber wir sind leider
in der situation dass wir uns eingraben
in unseren positionen bilateral wie
multilateral wir kommen nicht weiter
wenn wir uns weiterhin da drinnen ein
graben verehrte exzellenzen meine damen
und herren botschafter frau
aussenministerin herr bundespräsident
herr hofrat herr general und hausherr
meine herren
die strategische die gesellschaft für
politisch strategische studien und in
diesem haus in der lage hat schon viele
bedeutende vorträge erlebt ich glaube
aber doch nichts übertreiben wenn ich
sage diese streaming veranstaltung heute
war sicherlich eine sternstunde
ich wünsche der frau bundesministerin
tanner alles gute wenn sie das
bundesheer ins 21 jahrhundert führt die
stratec ist mit der heutigen
veranstaltung bereits im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert angekommen
ich möchte mich auch ganz besonders
bedanken bei ihnen frau fischer rasieren
man heute begleitet haben vielen dank
für ihr kommen
der bundespräsident diese diskussion
bitte ich mich gehorsamst nicht
einzumischen
ich möchte noch darauf hinweisen dass
bücher zum erwerb dort am tisch für sie
ausgelegt sind falls es noch nicht
gelesen haben oder lesen wollen
und ich darf sie jetzt noch namen der
vereine die immer zusammen
diese veranstaltungen machen also der
gesellschaft für landesverteidigung und
sicherheitspolitik und den freunden der
landesverteidigungsakademie dass
präsident heute uns die ehre seiner
anwesenheit gibt noch so ein paar frisch
und in das offizierskasino und zu
weiteren gesprächen mit dem gebotenen
corona abstand einladen
vielen dank für ihr kommen und noch
interessante gespräche danke sehr
[Applaus]
habe ich mir noch erlauben an die damen
und herren damen und herren des podiums
ein paar erinnerungsgeschenke zu
überreichen
liebe karin die blume zu blume seehofer
was für die moderation übernommen hast
und die historische 1 begleitung gegen
dank dafür
meine damen und herren ich bedanke mich
und verabschiede mich von den zuhörern
über den livestream und wünschen noch
einen schönen abend
[Applaus]